la parole est à Madame Perrine Goulet
pour le groupe démocrate
merci madame la Présidente merci tout
d'abord pour vos félicitations merci
aussi pour la constance vos engagements
pour le droit des enfants c'est aussi
cela qui redonnera confiance la
confiance qui peut faire des fois à nos
institutions je veux également remercier
les collègues membres de la délégation
parlementaire au droit de des enfants
nouvellement installés qui m'ont fait
confiance pour en prendre la présidence
la création d'une nouvelle délégation
aux envieux forts je mesure le poids et
la charge qui est la mienne va souffler
l'énergie nécessaire à ce que cette
délégation façoeuvre utile je sais que
nous y arriverons car les enfants et
leur protection dépassent les clivages
partisans et les sujets sont nombreux
harcèlement pauvreté éducation numérique
prostitution violence intrafamiliale
protection de l'enfance l'enfant et la
justice c'est bien d'autres
en lien direct madame la Présidente mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse
logiquement à madame la secrétaire
d'État chargée de l'enfance voilà trois
ans en 2019 sous la précédente
législature avec mes collègues nous
rendions 18 propositions issues de la
mission d'information sur l'aide sociale
à l'enfance adopté alors à l'unanimité
la délégation parlementaire au droit des
enfants et figurait parmi d'autres
depuis la protection des enfants demeure
une priorité comme là encore rappelé le
présent de la République récemment
madame la ministre pour rendre cette
action efficace l'état fait le choix
voit la 3 ans de reprendre une place et
de contractualiser avec les départements
autour des politiques de protection des
enfants mais également d'organiser deux
stratégies pour lutter contre les
violences faites aux enfants et pour
leur protection trois années après
pourriez-vous préciser devant la
représentation nationale les bilans que
vous pouvez tirer de ces politiques et
les ajustements que vous entendez
apporter pour ces futurs contrats je
vous remercie merci beaucoup